i was always like a hermit didn't want
to go out anything like that for
collecting it's just finding that unique
item that i can add to my collection
that makes a set complete or starts a
whole nother branch of collecting for me
hi my name is curtis shoyers and i
collect smurf memorabilia
never tallied it up fully but i would
say everything is about 100 000 plus
you know but i never actually went
through and said this piece that you
know and it fluctuates new collectors
come in they're willing to spend the
money you know it it fluctuates greatly
so you know i would
roughly say about a hundred thousand
dollar value for everything
[Music]
i'm part of a smurf community online
and a gentleman by the name of steve
parks had it in england he was the first
one to have it he shared his collection
and people would say well how many do
you have i'm like well i think i got
more than him well you should go for the
record i'm like no no no i'm not going
for that no way so one day i just kind
of
dared myself to step out of my comfort
zone put in the application to attempt
it and
you know as soon as i started the
process of counting i'm like i'm not
going to get this you know talking
myself out of it it wasn't until i saw
my name
on guinness world record
until i saw my name on there that's when
all of a sudden it was like
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh i like
literally called my husband up and says
go look at this page my name is on there
am i seeing this right
and he's like yup you're on there so
these are all the pvc smurfs and they're
in order of when they were released
starting from the top
all the way through
to
the newest ones i never expected you
know my name to be
known around the world
i've made some really great friends
around the world who's who've helped me
collect a lot of this stuff made
connections you know with people that i
don't think i ever would have made
connections with had it not been for
collecting
a wonderful little community we have
setting stuff up and
you know
sharing and helping each other's
collections grow
the bag and
the magnets
i got from a lady in hong kong that's
helping us out get stuff from
that area of the world
these are actually movie theater
banners
that
somebody
either smuggled out or whatever stuff
that was supposed to be thrown away so
that's what these are is the two movie
theater banners
i got some of the newest ones in here
this is a village that's being released
a little bit at a time
that comes with its own
comic book
so these are kind of
fun once it gets set up it'll look
really really nice
[Music]
when i was little my brother and i had
him as toys
and we used to play with him and
everything like that i was maybe
six maybe a little younger than that and
we had him as toys and he started
chewing on one of them
and i saw him break it and i was like
nope it can't happen so i gathered
everything up hid it in my room and just
started going out and finding stuff from
my little soccer
and of all of um i mean
he's still my favorite you know it
started it all
and
you know it's
it's still my favorite
and you could see why i took it from him
i mean
yeah
so this is just one of my binders of
animation cells
and i have
some of the original backgrounds used in
the
hanna-barbera
shows
and these are all
hand-painted
i'm definitely going to keep collecting
it's just a fun little escape from
everything that's going on especially
you know having people set stuff aside
around the world that you can you know
buy because there's great friends out
there that are willing to do that and
it's just fun i mean i got no intention
of stopping
you